kamilla caballos lead as she kicked off
the 2019 Grammy Awards and from Travis
Scott to Chloe and Halle the
performances from music's biggest night
did not disappoint I'm having so much
fun I feel so blessed I feel grateful
I've been a part of the Grammy community
for ten years now and just to be here to
celebrate all these beautiful artists is
wonderful and I'm just happy for
everyone and I can't wait to perform
[Music]
lady gaga brought the houses down
performing shallow after her Grammy win
how was it how did it feel I had a great
time man I loved playing music and I
just loved everybody in that room well
you ready for this let's kick some ass
that's your dad's here is it I'm nervous
yeah he's here everybody's here we're
just hanging out making trouble so I'm
gonna pound this and get to work clothes
Malone joined the Red Hot Chili Peppers
for an epic medley et caught him
backstage after the performance pose how
was it how was her stun the stadium with
hard place
[Music]
that was a real celebration what did
that moment feel like to you oh my gosh
um everything in my life that has
happened from the minute I was born led
me to this point so I just feel like wow
I'm exactly where I'm supposed to be I'm
only 21 years old and I'm at the Grammys
Janelle Monae donned a latex in her
iconic make me feel performance there's
just a magnificent party be slayed her
latest hit money with her amazing
pianist Chloe flower little big town
Miley Cyrus Kacey Musgraves Katy Perry
and Maren Morris joined forces to honor
Dolly Parton
how was that moment pretty epic just
sang with dolly and all my friends I'm
just on cloud nine right now I'm so
happy for dolly she's got an amazing
week
JLo brought her moves to Motown I could
cry it's such a good moment I said so I
just this is a soundtrack for so many
people's lives Motown looking out for
mine I grew up my mom was a young mom
and she used to you know have us in the
living room there's a nice thing and
it's singing up there with Smokey
Robinson I'm like I got to pinch myself
I can't I grew up on all those songs and
because my mom loved him so much that
she passed him on to us and is this a
dream come true
Diana Ross graced us with a legendary
performance and there was an amazing
tribute to the late great Aretha
Franklin what was that moment like it's
just so great it's all about the
audience they are so wonderful it's all
filled with love and it's just fantastic
what was your favorite performance of
the night stick with et online.com for
more coverage of the 2019 Grammy Awards
[Music]
[Applause]